animation is often the x-factor that
separates remarkable apps from ordinary
apps in this episode I'm going to cover
five different concepts related to
angular animations including a few new
concepts that were introduced in angular
4.2 angular animations are built on the
web animations API which is very similar
to css3 animations if you're not
comfortable with animation at all I
recommend doing some practice with css3
first and then you'll be able to make
the most out of angular's animation
module the first step to get started is
to import the browser animation module
into whatever module you plan on using
animations in this first example I'm
going to create a fade-in fade-out
animation that will show some content in
a popover when a button is clicked we
import the methods we need from the
animation module and then we'll create a
boolean variable show that will
determine the visibility of the popover
I also create a getter called state name
which will return the boolean variable
as a string either show or hide which we
need when defining the animation itself
in the HTML we use animations by
prefixing the animation name with the @
symbol and then pass at the current
state of whatever variable we're going
to animate in this case the only
possible values will be show or hide and
then we add a button for the user to
toggle this variable the end result
should look something like this it's
just a simple div that fades in and
fades out when that button is clicked
every component has an animations
property which accepts an array first we
pass it a trigger which corresponds to
the name with the @ symbol in the HTML
then we define how each state should
look once the animation is complete when
that popover is being shown the opacity
is 1 when it's hidden the opacity of 0
to actually make this animate we need to
define a transition which sets the time
parameter for the animation to occur in
this case when we transition from show
to hide it will animate in 600
milliseconds and ease out and then when
we transition from hide to show it will
transition in a thousand milliseconds or
one second with an ease in and the end
result is that simple fade in/fade out
animation
now we're going to build an animation
that can handle multiple different
states here we have a photo gallery
component and we're going to represent
its state with the position variable
then we'll add a few buttons for the
user to change the state on the
front-end then we'll apply the photo
State trigger to the image itself the
goal is to have the user click these
buttons and have the animation go from
state to state seamlessly so again we
start by defining the trigger and then
we have three different states that we
need to define the move state will move
the image across the screen we do this
by using the transform and translate X
which means translate on the x axis if
you've used css3 animations this should
look very familiar to you
you can adjust the position using both a
percentage or pixel value to enlarge the
image we'll use the transform scale
which will increase the size the image
by a factor of 1.5 to spin the image
we'll use the transform rotate and this
takes degrees as arguments and operates
on all three axes so now we have four
possible States including the default
state and that gives us 16 possible
combinations to animate it'd be very
cumbersome to define each transition
individually but angular offers a
wild-card option which we can use to
apply the transition to every different
possible state so here we apply the
wild-card is a 500 millisecond ease back
in the app we can now see that each of
these 16 combinations will use the 500
millisecond transition what if you
wanted to control the intermediate steps
in an animation you can do this with
keyframes
first make sure you import the keyframe
this method into your component then
we'll use the keyframes as an argument
to the animate method inside the
transition keyframes represent points
and time relative to the length of the
animation itself so in this example we
have a $2,000 second transition so an
offset of 0.33 would represent
approximately 660 milliseconds in this
example we're just translating and
rotating
the image all over the screen just to
demonstrate how keyframes can create
nonlinear animations back in the app we
can see the image moves to the right and
then up before reaching its final
resting state another cool feature about
angular animations is the ability to run
callbacks when an animation is either
started or finished in this example
we're just going to console.log the
animation and its current state
animation callbacks are really similar
to button clicks or any other user of
that we simply called a photo state dot
start and then fire whatever function we
want to fire then back in the type
script we just create a function that
will handle the console login for us
this is especially useful if you want to
run a sequence of animations in a very
choreographed kind of way the last
animation feature I want to talk about
is lists animations which uses two
features that are new and angular 4.2
the new query method allows you to
select elements that are nested within
an animation based on their HTML tag in
this case we'll use it to query all the
images nested within an animation
context
once we've queried those images we can
use stagger to create a delay between
each animation of each image creating a
shutter like effect we start by defining
the trigger and then the transition
we'll just use the wild-card then we can
query every image that is nested within
that trigger and first we'll get the
images and translate them off the screen
then we add an animation within the
context of stagger which will stagger
each item in the collection by 600
milliseconds in most cases you would
make the stagger delay a little bit
faster but I'll keep it slow for this
example in the template we have the
animation trigger to it div passing the
length of the collection to it and then
we loop over a collection of photos
because these images are nested within
the photos animation the query selector
will automatically grab all the images
and put them into an array
back in the app we see that each image
slicing the screen one after the other
that's it for angular animation basics
if this video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you want to support the
channel consider becoming a pro member
at angular firebase comm you'll get
access to a free copy of my book as well
as free one on one project consulting
thanks for watching and I'll see you
soon
[Music]